the fabric in a vicuna suit costs me to
the guy who's designing and making it
fifty five hundred dollars per yard are
you serious
i [ __ ] you not if i go by two chains
two chains i'm over the top sometimes
wow
seriously and right now we're going to
check out the most expensive
[ __ ] it's definitely crazy
yo what up what up it's your player
partner checking in two chains
and today on the most expensive this
[ __ ] we're gonna holla at my man
david lance out of new york has some of
the most
expensive suits that you've ever seen
let's go check them out
our collection is called david lance
private i like to set trends i like to
be a trendsetter instead of a trend
follower
we will custom design your wardrobe from
a to z
i like that i will style them exactly
how you want or need them to be styled
you just want to show your fancy bar off
david your bar of ties
if you drop 10 pounds or you gain 10
pounds whatever needs to be done
we take care of it those are the little
things that you're going to kind of go
wow you do that
we do that you know me having you on
speed that will be very important once
we leave we got you back
man it doesn't matter if you're on wall
street it doesn't matter if you're on
broad street
in your clothing we got your cup we do
it all so y'all do like
mostly one of one type of things just
just we
do want to try this you might want to
say you know what i want to have a coat
i want to know that there is nobody
most likely walking around the street
who's got a coat like that guy but just
for me i don't have to worry about
bumping to anybody
on the inside of your suit it's going to
say david lance
so i look at it like it's mark what do
you feel about you know jury on your
suit do you say
yo two chains maybe one chain and a
watch or a ring this suit is too
sophisticated for you to put all this
[ __ ] on it two chains you can wear
whatever you want with it
all right your personality is your
personality and that's why they love it
that's what you understand two chains we
all want to make money and have it and
spend it our suits
go between 7 500 and 9 500
we also have things that are much rarer
than that things like vicuna
what's the difference between and let's
say cashmere goat it's just
rare so a vicuna suit would be fifty
thousand dollars a vicuna top coat is
about sixty thousand dollars i wanna
feel some vacuum
can't blame it i could sleep with it
there you go
yeah yeah it's nice and soft and i'll
probably get a roll
a pajama suit made in there
that would be dope and he'd be running
around the backyard and you'd sure
i just yeah and i just have to shave
them just groom them up
and send them to you and say man i want
some socks made
i want to get friendly with your body i
want to know your shoulders and how
you're built and that everything's right
i'm getting intimate here too
you like touching on me scotty you
change your 6'5
i'm six five five two six yeah about 46
extra long 52 eggs long
i would probably put my pants right here
your mom would have you when i'm high
yeah my momma gonna make me pull up my
britches my daughter too
daddy pull up your pet you're gonna win
that they're not low
they're a little low my weight's right
here where are they supposed to be david
and these bridges here though he got him
on top of that we'll tweak the pattern
and do what we have to do to make sure
that that's ready to go
and then we can rock and roll when do i
get my wardrobe so typically
four to eight weeks from the time we
pick out what we're doing
you're wearing it i'm excited we got you
back we got you back
this is nice man you like this box and
hell yeah i like that patricia
that is one of those boxes i hope you
enjoy it thank you man
you liked it i figured you got to have
one i appreciate that
let's see that's that comes out by the
way that's just like a piece of paper
yeah it's going to come out very shortly
all right my man thanks for everything
see you guys so
take it easy all right thank you so much
did you see the fabrics
did you see the material me personally i
can't wait for my balcony suit
one of one red carpet swag you feel me
i mean what you think leave a comment
subscribe to the gq channel
for more most expensive [ __ ]